quel bonheur
quel honneur de monter sur scène après
tous ces gens
pointe de leur domaine dites moi dans la
salle qui compte bien demain être à la
pointe de son domaine levé la main sur
elle est super excellent en général
maintenant une question un peu plus
délicate voire embarrassante qui
aujourd'hui est obsolète
on sent le malaise tout on n'ose pas
levé la monnaire vous n'êtes pas obligé
de lever la main je pense que je pas le
seul dans la salle avoir laissé périmés
quelques unes de mes compétences avoir
arrêté de les mettre à jour
si je vous dis ça c'est pas pour vous
culpabilisez peut-être un peu pour vous
provoquer en tout cas pour attirer votre
attention sur un phénomène qui nous
touche tous
l'obsolescence des compétences et si
vous êtes dans ce cas faut que je vous
présente quelques uns ce quelqu'un c'est
edwin le génie de la formation
professionnelle et aujourd'hui c'est
notre jour de chance parce que edwin
nous invite tous à choisir une
compétence n'importe laquelle il nous la
transmettra instantanément et un niveau
de maîtrise extraordinaire alors dans la
salle qui sait déjà ce que il ou elle
demanderait au génie la formation
professionnelle qui a déjà une idée
hockey n'est que quelques uns
donc gardé cette idée en tête et pour
les autres prenez bien le temps de
réfléchir
moi aussi je prends bien le temps de
réfléchir de quelles compétences
aurez-vous le plus besoin aujourd'hui
pour vous créer la carrière et par
extension le futur de vos rêves
alors si on posait cette question aux
générations précédentes celles qui ont
grandi dans l'ère industrielle
mais la question serait légèrement plus
simple à l'époque les trajectoires de
carrière oui c'est une trajectoire de
carrière était relativement rectiligne
c'est à dire qu'on passait un premier
quart de sa vie à s'éduquer et apprendre
un métier
la moitié suivante à exercer ce métier
et le
en restant à profiter d'une retraite
bien méritée ce schéma était simple
rassurant et respectable mais
malheureusement révolue aujourd'hui une
trajectoire de carrière elle ressemble
plutôt à ça
formation nous ont propulsés dans une
nouvelle ère on parle de transformation
numérique de l'économie celle ci impose
une métamorphose du marché de l'emploi
et des rails
quelque peu nos trajectoires de carrière
à côté de ça des innovations de rupture
détruisent des industries entières en
très peu de temps les métiers
disparaissent d'autres apparaissent et
tout son impact est de plus ou moins
près d'après une étude de mckinsey qui
est un brin anxiogène ce sera entre 400
et 800 millions d'emplois qui seraient
supprimés d'ici 2030 60 % des métiers
qui vont les remplacer n'existe pas
encore et pour ceux qui entrent sur le
marché de l'emploi
aujourd'hui ils peuvent s'attendre à
voir en moyenne 15 carrière alors ça ça
complique un peu la question que nous
pose le génie et de qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire plus tard dans ce nouveau schéma
la seule constante finalement c'est le
changement et il n'y a pas que les
chauffeurs de taxi de poids lourds les
caissiers qui sont affectés en fait de
l'automatisation et de la robotique
affecter n'importe quel métier du
télémark et heures au notaire en passant
par les intermédiaires de l'immobilier
du voyage de la banque de l'assurance de
la logistique
la liste est longue alors donc la
question se complique pourquoi investir
du temps dans une compétence ou un
métier si celui ci est en voie
d'extinction
la question est très compliqué mais pour
autant il faut pas se paralyser ce
qu'ils ne continuent pas de se former de
s'adapter vont de plus en plus
rapidement être laissées en marge ou sur
le bas côté
avec des qualifications pour des métiers
qui n'existent plus ça a déjà créé des
crises sociales ça continue d'en créer
si celle ci se multiplient ça pourrait
même déstabilisé nos sociétés alors
pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça moi je
suis ni économiste ni sociologue
en fait je suis designer pédagogiques
comme le génie je travaille dans la
formation
professionnel je travaille chez eux au
punk à thrones dans les technologies de
l'éducation et j'ai la chance inouïe et
peut-être éphémère de vivre de ma
passion et de ma mission qui est de
contribuer à accélérer la transformation
numérique n'ont pas de l'économie
directement mais bien de la formation
professionnelle justement pour nous
préparer à relever ensemble ces défis
sociétaux
alors pour vous rassurer je suis pas le
seul nous ne sommes pas les seuls à
plancher sur ces questions qui sont
gigantesques qui nous dépasse nous
sommes tout un écosystème un écosystème
qui essaie de proposer des solutions
innovantes qui prennent des formes
diverses et variées savez vous par
exemple qu'aujourd'hui vous pouviez
apprendre un métier en ligne depuis
votre ordinateur et obtenir un diplôme
reconnu par l'état saviez vous que vous
pouvez faire vos contrats d'alternance
au contrat pro entre l'entreprise et
votre ordinateur
d'autres acteurs sont aussi dans ce
domaine là ne sont pas forcément en
ligne et de nouveaux formats qui
apparaissent des formes a accéléré on
appelle ça les bouts de kanpe les écoles
et universités elles aussi commencent à
réussir brillamment à intégrer ces
nouvelles modalités dans les cursus
hybride mêlant présentiel et distant
ciel et tout ça pour permettre à
quiconque de se lancer se reconvertir ou
évoluer dans un métier tout au long de
sa vie dans les meilleures conditions
possibles c'est à dire sans se mettre
sans devant mettre sa vie entre
parenthèses ou se mettre en difficulté
financière alors toutes ces initiatives
dont je vous parlais elles sont deux
succès retentissant pour certains types
d'apprenants les plus autonomes en fait
et pour les autres et continue de poser
beaucoup de difficultés alors pour
sensibiliser lé public francophone pour
les aider à aborder cette nouvelle
posture d'apprentissage qui est
nécessaire pour ces nouveaux formats et
bien ya quelques temps j'ai créé un
cours en ligne plutôt un atelier
pratique en
une ouverte à tous et diffuser
massivement qui permet donc de
réapprendre cette posture
d'apprentissage de se définir une
stratégie d'apprentissage de se créer un
plan d'apprentissage et enfin de
s'initier à l'apprentissage accélérés
depuis
je suis heureux et ému de recevoir des
messages de gens de tout âge de tout
horizon que ça a pu aider à rebondir ou
à changer de vie donc je discute avec
des vendeurs en magasin devenu
webmarketeur une boulangère devenu chef
de projet digital un artisan devenu
développeurs ou encore un webmaster
devenu data analystes autant d'exemples
de gens qui ont su adapter cette posture
et rebondir dans ce nouveau paradigme
aujourd'hui je vais pas vous refaire
l'atelier en dix minutes j'ai pas le
pouvoir d'instantanéité du génie par
contre j'aimerais partager avec vous la
synthèse de ce que j'ai appris ma
prenant et en apprenant à mais apprenant
comment apprendre à apprendre
alors pour simplifier tout ça on
pourrait résumer les facteurs clés de
succès et les attitudes élémentaires
d'une bonne posture d'apprentissage en
cinq règles appelons les les cinq
recours l'année mots techniques
j'espère que vous aideront à aborder
votre futur professionnel avec plus de
facilité alors la règle numéro 1 c'est
la responsabilité à prendre est un verbe
d'action
une action que nous faisons pour nous
mêmes et pour le bien commun opposition
à une action qui nous est fait on ne
sait pas très bien comment on ne peut
donc plus être seulement objet de cette
action nous devons être son sujet à nous
donc d'adopter une responsabilité
personnelle et collective pour aller au
delà des apprentissages qui nous sont
prescrits pour aller vers plus
d'autonomie d'auto direction et de
proactivité construisons tous notre
propre plan d'apprentissage personnalisé
autrement dit faisons de notre formation
professionnelle une affaire personnelle
mais prendre les choses trop
personnellement ça comporte des risques
quand on s'engage émotionnellement
eh bien on se rend vulnérable échec
scolaire ne fait pas de cadeaux chez les
enfants il fait des ravages chez les
adultes
alors nous allons avoir besoin de
résilience pour avoir la confiance
d'aller nous frotter aux difficultés
désirable qui nous attendent et dont
nous avons tant besoin
nous allons avoir besoin de résilience
pour pouvoir rebondir lorsque les temps
seront durs
nous allons avoir besoin de résilience
pour rester fermes dans notre direction
mais flexible et adaptive dans notre
approche ensuite nous aurons besoin de
ressources et d'ingéniosité pour
apprendre apprendre et pratiquer
intelligemment délibérément en faisant
de choses réelles qui crée de la valeur
pour quelqu'un finit l'apprentissage in
vitro nous devons apprendre à identifier
des opportunités d'apprentissage dans
notre quotidien et à sélectionner et
user des bonnes ressources pour s'en
saisir
parmi ces ressources ne négligeons pas
les ressources humaines à ça je parle
des communautés d'apprentissage qui se
crée autour de chaque sujet d'étude
quand je parle d'apprentissage en ligne
avec des professionnels ou d'autres on
dit souvent que l'apprentissage en ligne
quelques chose de solitaire
aujourd'hui se connecter à des
communautés de pratiques à des réseaux
d'apprentissage est devenu tellement
accessible et pas facile que la solitude
est devenu plus un choix qu'une réelle
contrainte est un mauvais choix
si on me demandait mon avis allons donc
à la rencontre de nos pères apprenons 2
et ensuite devenons pour quelqu'un
d'autre
le mentor que nous aurions rêvé d'avoir
lorsque nous mêmes nous débutions enfin
le sujet de la reconnaissance est plus
important que jamais reconnaissante
d'abord de notre niveau de compétences
auprès de notre écosystème
alors où notre avantage compétitif
deviendra de plus en plus
d'apprentissage autonome et informel
sans autorité de certification et bien
et parcours de très longues
et les années d'expérience
professionnelle vous que les métiers
changent deviennent des proxys de moins
en moins fiables pour les recruteurs
nous retrouvons donc avec une
responsabilité de documenter et de
démontrer ce que nous apprenons pour
pouvoir en apporter des preuves
tangibles reconnaissance aussi envers
ceux qui nous offre des opportunités
d'apprentissage
alors comment dire ça sans remercier
mathieu nebra pierre dubuc tous mes
collègues et tous ceux qui m'ont appris
quoi que ce soit et bien sûr l'équipe
paris descartes pour nous avoir offert à
tous sept opportunités d'apprentissage
je me permettent de détourner
respectueusement la phrase célèbre je
pense donc je suis pour vous inviter à
vous l'approprier comme j'apprends donc
je suis j'apprends du verbe être parce
que nous sommes ce que nous savons nous
devenons qui nous sommes
au fil des apprentissages mais aussi
j'apprends donc je suis du verbe suivre
parce qu'il n'ya qu'en adoptant une
posture d'apprentissage constante que
nous pouvons suivre et rester dans la
course dans cette transition économique
alors si vous ne deviez retenir qu'une
seule chose de ce discours c'est que
votre outil le plus précieux contre
l'obsolescence des compétences c'est
votre capacité d'apprentissage
celle ci n'est pas figé un essence elles
se développent en fait c'est une
compétence une compétence clé qui peut
vous ouvrir les portes de n'importe quel
domaine
tout au long de votre vie soit pour
votre épanouissement professionnel ou
personnel
alors si un jour vous rencontrez un
gigantesque génie bleus un chargé de
ressources humaines un mentor ou un
parent et qui vous demande qu'est ce que
vous voulez apprendre dit lui j'aimerais
apprendre à apprendre et c'est comme si
vous aviez fait le voeu de faire autant
de voeux que vous le voulez merci
[Applaudissements]